en las zonas Rurales de Bolivia más
carcoca es parte de la vida misma y esto
se está extendiendo cada vez más a las
ciudades que con esta apropiación
también acaban con el estigma
beneficiándose de las propiedades de la
planta ancestral hoy en día lo consumen
todo de
doctores policías es como energizante
natural alivia mucho el estrés y se
quita te quita mucho
el cansancio este Boom tiene especial
peso en Santa Cruz la segunda ciudad de
Bolivia es el principal centro económico
y de recepción de migrantes los locales
al ver los efectos que tiene la coca en
los indígenas se han acercado a su
consumo y cada vez hay más iniciativas
desde saborizantes como la maracuyá
sofisticados brebajes y llega hasta las
exclusivas fiestas de la ciudad hay
mucho mucha gente que en Santa Cruz hay
una gente que en jamba tradicional
Como así está el su popularidad que ha
llegado a las esferas de la fama como
Daniel Novoa conocido como boloman con
más de 200.000 seguidores en tiktok con
vídeos humorísticos sobre la coca en la
mayoría
quizás todo no son menos de los que no
estoy volando el mercado de la coca solo
puede crecer en Bolivia la hoja
ancestral está clasificada como
substancia controlada por las Naciones
Unidas sin embargo Bolivia pudo crear
una excepción por la importancia de la
coca en el país